to an entrepreneur
an investor is somebody that you confide
in when you have difficulties somebody
that you can have meaningful
conversations with
who can challenge you
who can be a sounding board
somebody who can open up doors
reaction represents all of that
[Music]
your reaction was launched on campus
from the Stanford executive program this
idea of how do you bring a community
together that can Elevate entrepreneurs
experiences we had 225 leaders from
throughout the world every continent we
set a mission to improve A Billion Lives
this decade by scaling innovations that
would change the world I was all in
we have alumni from the Stanford
executive program classes all the way
from 2014 through 22. we really enjoyed
being together so the first thing we
thought about is hey how do we keep this
community going together we had three
problems we were trying to solve the
first was how could we continue to learn
I believe in lifelong learning the way
you consume information the way you
learn these days you know that has
changed forever the second was thinking
about what we could build we were a
group of 225 you realize the potential
and the power and then the third was
around purpose thinking about what we'd
want to look back on what we would be
proud about and to collectively
accomplish something that none of us
ever could have done individually
[Music]
so in terms of improving a billion wives
we focus on the macro problems of the
world in health of course heart disease
mental health chronic disease and most
recently sustainability
I became involved with reaction because
I am a founder of a local
biomanufacturing company and we were
looking for investors what mango
materials is focused on is changing the
Plastics industry completely so we're
looking for a very specific type of
investor one who sees the future in the
same way we do
we are technologists we are engineers
and scientists who've created this new
technology but we need partners and
investors to help us see this through
innovator like Molly has a lot of
support in terms of capital what we need
to do is to bring something to Maui
that's different
so reaction helps by facilitating the
scaling of the technology globally by
organizing a global set of Stanford
alumni into this fund we're able to help
her to open doors throughout the world
in a way that is creating more value and
improving more lives faster we see
climate change and plastic pollution is
two of the largest threats that our
planet is facing today in order for
these Solutions these Innovations the
science to reach the different parts of
the planet it can impact it needs to
have the leadership and the influence in
those areas and we can provide that so
by being part of an ecosystem of change
makers who believe the world can be
changed through novel Innovation and new
technologies and new business platforms
that gives us a path to the Future that
we all really want to see and in terms
of the industries that are impacted
between energy and health and
transportation and Manufacturing and
agriculture we have access to all these
different Industries play a unique role
in helping them to plug in and to
connect with the leaders that can
influence decisions proactively we can
help to solve the climate crisis
challenge
it's on campus at the GSB we focused a
lot on their slogan which is to change
lives change organizations and change
the world
naturally As Leaders come to Stanford
their lives are transformed they can
transform their organizations but
changing their world we thought we can
really play an important role changing
the world the the best thing you can do
is enable entrepreneurs to build
companies enable them to invest in
communities with global impact
makes reaction different is our
community of investors of Executives of
entrepreneurs throughout the world and
their desire to be Hands-On to be active
in terms of helping the innovators to
really take their Solutions further than
they can go on their own so our ambition
is to create the most Global most
influential and most impactful Stanford
investment community in the world we're
very proud of what's been accomplished
so far but so excited for where this is
going to go in the future and seeing
this stream really come to life
I'm Molly Morse CEO and co-founder of
mango materials my name is Babu
sivadasan one of the founding partners
of reaction I'm Dan Matthews I'm a
co-founder and managing partner of
reaction
[Music]